hi I'm axel ooga veer for details it's
been said that our thoughts shape our
spaces and our spaces return the favor
which make our homes then the ultimate
expression of not only who we are but
who we aspire to be Jo Sadler creative
director of LA's quest and the man who
created the coexist logo and menswear
brand Riviera Club now welcomes us into
his loft
I consider myself probably more of an
artist than a designer really so this is
really just a natural result of of
honestly spirituality in my life it's I
think creativity is the natural result
of spirituality so I think what I do
here is more of just an expression of
myself all things here whether it's
design designing a garment or picking
out I don't know coffee table books for
my table here it all comes from the same
same place it's just an expression of
creativity purest form of of who I am
lifestyle design is really what it is my
place is is very eclectic it's it's
filled with different styles from
different eras there was time in my life
where everything was minimal actually
everything was wide almost bright
painted my turntables white or whatever
reason that it's just evolved and I love
things now with soul things have been
broken in the natural patina on this
Chesterfield but I love that mixed with
some more I don't know chic elements for
a scandal holders just different things
from different eras that sort of come
together naturally to create one
aesthetic that just wouldn't exist in
and of itself Los Angeles yes is
incredibly special place to me I think
California in general has always meant
something to me I grew up dreaming of
palm trees vintage Porsches and blonde
girls on the beach yeah there's just an
effortless sensibility out here it's
just timelessly cool always will be
think people look to California as they
do on the East Coast for what's next
what's the future hold it's just it just
constantly inspired me being that I'm
from
and not used to palm trees my friends
are why you love palm trees they're so
tired of palm trees they grew up a palm
trees was still to this day I just like
that's the most beautiful tree and I've
ever seen the house was on fire what
what would I what would I grab first my
dad has a it's a 19 I believe 47 Gibson
master town that he gave me it was a
birthday present I had no idea that this
big box came in the mail and opened it
up and it was his his banjo this prized
possession they had forever in fact my
mom when she went in labor with me they
were at this Music Festival and he was
playing this banjo it's just really a
sentimental piece that's something
always hold you know dear to the heart
there's just beauty in the instruments
and what what they're capable of in the
stories behind them and it's natural
artwork I mean it just it's always it's
always going to be cool it's it's sort
of effortless design if you will it's
not contrived you don't really have to
try you hang a guitar on the wall and it
just it's just cool the art I have is
all extremely personally I think it
should be for people it needs to mean
something to you I can show you
something that's cool but it's got to
mean something to you so actually
everything and I have you know means
something really significant to me
things that come they come from
everywhere a lot of the instruments I
brought from from Indiana I packed my
parents sedan and drove cross-country
for three four days a lot of the stuff
comes from flea markets the Rose Bowl is
some of the most amazing offerings of
all things vintage you know buy and sell
trade stuff a lot as well I love to when
I travel always stopping in at little
thrift stores the large piece here on
the gallery walls it's the first time I
ever spit money on art a good friend of
mine Gary Widener is a broke college kid
and I threw him five hundred dollars for
painting
the time was a lot of money for me but
it said something about our friendship
and said something about how much I
believed in what he was doing and his
talent his skill and it really just
spoke to me the best camera that that
one could own is one that's you know
with you at all times regardless what a
dish it was just something about the
contrast of this black and white tree
rings I just love the center focus of
the trunk I just thought it'd be a good
idea to slice it down the middle and
separate in two portraits above the
couch the the view here is really
special
I found the space and it wasn't finished
and I came in put a deposit on it but it
instead of two to three weeks to move in
it turned out to be three months so
while they were working on it I would
come up and I would sit in the loft and
just kind of look out over the city it
was just I don't know it's kind of
refuge for me it so it's a little bit
weird I would grab my coffee in the
morning just come here there are no
blinds no window coverings it's actually
quite private up there but it just has
the most epic sunsets and the moon is
incredible at night it actually wakes me
up sometimes it's so bright it's just
like this sweet just beautiful place of
refuge so tranquil it just it's a place
to come home to and feel that peace and
and relax